the NFL season is just 18 weeks long but
that's actually longer than the time it
took the federal government to borrow $1
trillion during week two of this NFL
season the national debt hit $33
trillion by week 18 the national debt
had surpassed $34 trillion before covid
America only ran trillion doll annual
deficits four times now we're borrowing
that much money in less than 4 months
this is unsustainable and Runaway
government spending is to blame since
2019 Baseline federal spending has
exploded from $4.4 trillion to more than
$6 trillion and that doesn't include
trillions in emergency covid spending
tax revenue is increasing too but not
fast enough to keep up so we have to
borrow more and the debt gets bigger
Congress needs to cut spending now
before the national debt sacks the
economy